حيث وجددت القوات التركيه قصف مواقع ما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه شمال
الشرقيه سوريا وقالت وزاره والدفاع
التركيه انها حيدت 14 عنصرا من مسلحي حزب
العمال الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه
وافادت مصادر محليه للجزيره نقصا مدفعيا
تركيا قال مواقع لما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في قرى بمحيطي عين العرب
الحدوديه مع تركيا
المتميزه في مناطق المعارضه الشماليه حلب
مواقع قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في محيط
بلده تل رفعه في حلب وفق المصادر ذاتها
اقل ما تقوم باسم الرئاسه التركيه ابراهيم
قالن ان العمليه العسكريه التركيه البريه
قد تبدا في اي وقت واين ذلك يعتمد على
تقييم المراجع المعنيه
واكد كالين ان تركيا لم تستهدف حتى الان
اي جنود امريكيين او روس وان هدفها الوحيد
هو وحدات وحمايه الشعب الكرديه الموجوده
في شمال سوريا
وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه في مناطق تبعد
30 كلم عن الحدود التركيه وان تتوقف عن
محاوله التسلل الى تركيا وقال ان العمليات
العسكريه التركيه قطعت الطريقه على تاسيس
ممر ارهابيا من الحدود العراقيه واصولا
الى البحر المتوسط